Since we no longer have a normal distribution, but a t distribution, we have a
new table. This is called the t table, unlike the z table, the t table tells us
the critical values in the body. And up here, the column rows are the area in
the right tail. On the left we have the degrees of freedom. Remember I said
that t distributions are defined by their degrees of freedom. And then on the x
axis of the t distributions, we have the t values instead of the z values. In
this case we only really care about the t critical values. So let's say we have
a t distribution and we want to know the t critical value such that. 10% is in
the tail here, or a proportion of 0.1. And let's say that our sample size is
10, so our degrees of freedom is 9. So this is a t distribution with 9 degrees
of freedom. And we want to find this t critical value. Well here in the tails,
we look for 0.1. And with 9 degrees of freedom, we see that the t critical
value is 1.383. You're going to use this t table to do pretty much the exact
same thing you did with a z table. But instead of finding the z score and then
determining if that z score is bigger or less than the z critical value. We
find the t statistic and we figure out if the t statistic is greater or less
than the t critical value. Let's practice using the t table.